Film Courage: Should a beginning Youtuber aim to make
the best videos? You know there's so many
to "compete" with, it' very
intimidating. Or try another approach? Josh Yeo, MAKE.ART.NOW Youtube Channel: I
think a beginning Youtuber should try to
just be as genuine and as grounded as
they can be and it sounds simple but
those are the types of videos that
really respond I mean as an audience you
have this uncanny ability to sniff out
when someone's not being there their
authentic self and one of the things
that I always really appreciate was when
someone was authentic enough to show us
a glimpse of their life the good stuff
but also like the not-so-good stuff
right to be on the same level as us so
that you leave feeling like wow I
actually know that person like I've been
there I've experienced those things I
think I think that's actually a trait
it's like it's something you have to
work on when I first started if you
watch that very first video that I
uploaded you see a lot of flexing it's a
lot of like I'm validating myself
therefore you must watch me and I can't
tell like that makes me cringe now
because it should just be the work or
the message or whatever it is that
you're trying to convey that is the
validation right like what you're trying
to teach is validating if it's good
it'll validate you don't have to be like
oh look at all these accolades I have
and this is why I'm worthy of your time
none of that stuff it's just the body of
work should be enough to validate so if
you compare like my later videos you
definitely see a change of me trying to
do implement more of like the grounded
approach of like no more flexing instead
I do a reverse flex which is like I like
this is what I'm really terrible at you
know I mean and show and really like
show the cracks show the flaws I'm
really into that right now so I think
you grow into the work to like maybe and
I'm just speaking for myself but you
kind of have a different reason when you
started then when you start continuing
because it's not an easy thing so
usually that first reason doesn't work
anymore yeah I mean there's definitely
thing that's trying to be satiated with
doing the YouTube videos I mean I
recently left my CNBC job so now I'm
doing YouTube full-time but I still seem
to be pointing out just as many videos
so it's kind of weird but there's
something in there that I'm in addition
to obviously making a living doing it
there's something in there that I'm
trying to unearth trying to figure out
and it's fair to say that I don't
actually know what that is there's
something though maybe but maybe one day
I will know maybe I won't know I don't
know how many videos are you working on
at a time and do you finish everything
you start no that's actually the
downfall one of my one of my downfalls
if I were to give advice to someone
starting YouTube it would be work at one
video work on one video at a time and
then don't even start the next one until
that one is finished unfortunately I
don't follow that I am I have like four
videos that I'm trying to get out right
now I'm currently backlogged on them and
trying to finish him up and I wish that I didn't have that work ethic
where I could just be like it's done
it's finished and move on to the next
because it would probably let me pump
out videos quicker but each one is just
as important so it makes it harder I
think if I do start to switch over to
one video at a time you will see more
videos on a consistent basis but there
are a ton of videos that I have shot
that simply have not seen the light of
day and too much time has passed now
that I don't feel like they're worth my
time to pursue to finish because they're
not they're no longer relevant or the
you know that yes too much times gone by
kind of a downer topic for me well I
think that's common for a lot of artists
to start things and kind of leave them I
hope so right it's not just me feels
like oh like a man on an island you know
you